if I could pick one devil fruit to eat I  would pick Marco's Phoenix fruit why  easy first it looks freaking fantastic  second it gives you the ability to fly  now I don't know about you but that's  one thing I wish I could do Above All  Else three it's basically a mix between  all three categories as a Zone it gives  you a speed and power boost then just  like a paramecia we have its healing  abilities and it's pretty much a fire  logia fruit though here your body just  regenerates really really fast but  that's actually even better because if  you get hit with sea prisms on a hockey  as a low gear user you take real damage  as a phoenix I just heal my body  afterwards not only am I fast but I can  also tank some of the most destructive  powers out there and the best thing is  all of these are great abilities to have  even if you're not fighting a  world-ending war now excuse me I'm  suddenly craving some pineapple